et bonsoir c'est mon plan alors pourquoi
pourquoi les techno sont si affectés
suite autant cette année on voit au
dernier trimestre c'est vraiment la
jonction de facteurs les dernières
années durant la période covid le modèle
d'affaires de société là va vraiment le
vendre dans les voiles donc qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé c'est que les dirigeants
ont établi des plans des budgets
significatifs pour investir massivement
pour s'adapter à cette réalité-là qu'on
pensait prendre qu'elle a duré plus
longtemps mais aussi pour adapter le
modèle d'affaires vers l'avenir donc on
voit une progression des dépenses et là
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans les derniers
mois on voit que le consommateur est
pivoté avec la réouverture de l'économie
vers la consommation de service plutôt
que bien durable les vendeurs qui vont
directement consommateurs ont des enjeux
d'inventaire avec la chaîne
d'approvisionnement et aussi on voit que
la médecine des banques centrales
commence à faire son effet donc ce qui
se passe tous ces facteurs-là ensemble
on voit des ventes puis des projections
de vente pour le prochain trimestre la
prochaine année en baisse lorsqu'on
conjugue ces deux facteurs là mais la
réalité c'est que 2023 pour les une
société de technologie la rentabilité
elle va être plus mince que ce qu'on a
vu dans le passé et fondamentalement
pour Facebook qu'est-ce qui se passe
pour qu'on perde 70% de la valeur de
l'entreprise en bourse mais premièrement
si on regarde à l'été l'année dernière
il y avait des gens une période de
spéculation sur enchères sur les titres
technologiques puis il y avait vraiment
une expansion des multiples donc premier
facteur c'est le retour à la réalité les
multiples qu'on a vu dans le passé c'est
derrière nous qu'un réajustement de la
valeur donc c'est la première étape où
on a vu des titres comme méthode
Facebook et ou Microsoft et autres BC
deuxième facteur là on regarde le modèle
à faire de facebook puis Mark Zuckerberg
l'équipe de direction investit vraiment
vers des initiatives comme le mette
avant puis jusqu'à présent on peut pas
dire qu'on voit des résultats donc je
donne un exemple mais la direction de
Facebook s'attendait environ à avoir 500
000 utilisateurs dans les coût système
qui touche qu'on appelle realitylab le
mettraval on est à 200 000 donc là les
non seulement ça trimestre qu'on vient
d'avoir l'équipe de direction on dit
l'enveloppe budgétaire les coûts pour
l'année prochaine finalement ce sera pas
85 milliards ça va être 100 milliards
donc on voit que l'équipe de direction
continue sur la même direction c'est
comme un puissant fond un moment donné
le metaves cet univers virtuel
tridimensionnel ou multidimensionnelle
où on va pouvoir faire toutes sortes de
choses
vous croyez à ça mais tavers vous je
pense que beaucoup de sociétés qui
investissent massivement il y a un
potentiel par contre de là ce qu'on voit
des résultats à court terme quand je
parle le terme sur un an deux ans
moi personnellement je parlais sans ma
convaincu qu'on regarde la communauté
d'investisseurs non plus et donc les
investisseurs doutent de la stratégie
d'investissement cette stratégie massive
d'investissement de Mark Zucker dans le
métabeur ouais et puis combiné avec des
enjeux qu'on voit que facebook
l'application est une grande utilisation
mais à la tête maturité en Amérique du
Nord on voit que le modèle d'affaires de
instagram est intéressant mais il y a
des nouveaux compétiteurs comme qui
gagne vraiment des parts de marché donc
quand on vient toutes ces facteurs de
risque là les investisseurs se posent
vraiment des questions et on voit la
publicité c'est aussi les revenus
publicitaires
capter en bonne partie par les Gafa ou
les gafams depuis un certain temps les
revenus publicitaires baissent parce que
l'économie ralenti on a vu Amazon
aujourd'hui YouTube on va aussi sur
facebook
la vente directement consommateur le
commerce en ligne ralenti pour des
enjeux d'approvisionnement mais aussi le
consommateur qui change ses habitudes
puis un ralentissement économique on
peut voir est-ce que si ça a été gonflé
pendant la pandémie est-ce que c'est
exagéré 3000 milliards pour cette
entreprise de recul de valeur boursière
je pense que oui dans une certaine
mesure 2023 ça va être une année que
beaucoup d'inconnus par contre je veux
juste relativiser les choses donnent un
exemple metta au troisième trimestre
affiché des ventes de 27 milliards en
baisse de 4% par rapport à l'année
dernière mais l'année dernière c'était
exceptionnel si je la compare au même
trimestre de 2019
avant le covid mettant avait des ventes
de 17 milliards pas de 27 donc sur une
période de trois ans il y a quand même
une certaine progression ce modèle
d'affaires donc je pense que en ce
moment le marché est vraiment en mode
s'éloigner du risque il y a beaucoup
d'inquiétudes sur le modèle d'affaires à
court terme par contre c'est société là
ont quand même des bonnes marges de
profit et des modèles d'affaires
intéressants sur la numérisation du
monde des affaires sur une période de
3,50 je pense qu'on prévoir quand même
des bonnes surprises éventuellement
pourquoi Apple s'en sort mieux que les
autres Apple il y a vraiment un modèle
d'affaires très rentable lorsqu'on
regarde méthode qui voit une baisse de
sa profitabilité de 50%. on regarde les
marges de profit de Apple c'est vraiment
soutenable on voit la ligne de produits
qui est à venir pour la période des
fêtes on peut s'attendre des bons
résultats puis aussi son modèle à faire
à migrer si on monte il y a quelques
années à Paul vendait des biens mais
maintenant toute son écosystème peut
être rentable avec par exemple à Paul
music etc donc on voit que ce modèle là
semble plus robuste dans l'environnement
qu'on est
[Musique]